in Call of Duty infinite warfare the
trip from Earth to outer space takes
mere seconds the beauty of this brief
scene is its matter-of-factness that the
ease of traveling to space is as simple
as pulling out of the driveway this
moment in all its science fictionalized
spectacle is emblematic of the rest of
the campaign where it's indelible cast
has little time to be impressed with
advanced technologies they're too busy
fighting an intergalactic war judgement
that is why do you come up with the
stories infant warfare showpiece a rare
finally constructed Call of Duty story
that manages to outshine its multiplayer
components including a highly involving
zombies cooperative mode infinite
warfare campaign kicks off with a
classic sci-fi trope where humanity's
drive to colonize other worlds is
motivated by Earth's dwindling resources
colonization and time give rise to the
off-worlders quest for independence the
version of this group in infinite
warfare dubbed the settlement defense
front takes the aggressive approach
restricting the earthbound forces
resources with blockades erasing them to
colonize new moons and planets when you
take the controls who promptly
experience the savagery of the SDF
firsthand
after the initial dust settles
protagonist Nick Reyes undergoes a trial
by fire due to a sudden promotion the
command of his own ship and a
desperation to repel the SDF threat XO
no longer with us man
all this happened in the crash yes sir
so who has the car Gator
it's the highest-ranking officer on
board I believe you do sir
it's a campaign that only lasts five to
seven hours but infinite Warfare's
writers crafted a cast of characters
with a level of death as significant as
any of the modern warfare series one
example is Nora Salter Ray is as
dependable wing woman who up until
recently was the same rank as Reyes
naturally his promotion create some
tension between the two but not
necessarily with the predictable outcome
one might expect hey Nick yeah you can
do this do the best we've got high
praise coming from you Nora this sci-fi
tale doesn't have any aliens but its
star isn't human
Ethan a robotic naval petty officer
represents a new definition of a perfect
military warrior a strong dependable
teammate who can also soften a tense
moment he proves handy in every
firefight but his greatest gift is his
wit you got feelings Ethan I do
lieutenant I do I carry the brain of a
human farmer holy [ __ ] are you serious
no man not lieutenant not he's your
copilot and introduces you to infinite
Warfare's exquisite spacecraft combat
it's a thrill to chase targets through
tight gaps in round corners the only
scene missing is a trench run on a moon
sighs battle station its most intense
moments occur when enemies match your
level of agility and aggression forcing
you to go on the defense as you try to
shake them off with sharp turns and
salvos of diversionary flares
you
because
it's disappointing to miss out on the
thrill of space combat in a competitive
multiplayer environment what you have
instead are the usual tournament ready
modes a familiar playlist of match types
that take no chances with new ideas
these include the oddball inspired
defender mode and the team deathmatch
alternative Kill Confirmed much like
prior Call of Duty competitive Maps it
only takes a few team deathmatch
sessions to get the lay of the land
there's elegance in the simplicity of
the maps although they lack imaginative
design partly due to an overabundance of
right angles multi players mid-match and
profile progression rely on a classic
reward loop that recognizes skill and a
devotion to play matches for hours on
end
two new notable unlocks are the eraser
which has the cold efficiency of
vaporizing its target instantly and the
claw which fires a horizontal rain of
ricocheting bullets these enhancements
add variety to the matches there are
weapons that are even useful in the
hands of novice players
oh you've got to be kidding me
Zombies is in the music contrast to the
campaign and that this is a cooperative
multiplayer mode that is bereft of
subtlety titled Spaceland
this futuristically style theme-park is
the first of a number of plans Amba maps
for infinite warfare thematically
packaged as movie settings zombies
presents a risk versus reward scenario
where opening up additional sections of
space land as soon as possible may not
be the best strategy new areas present
new gear and zombie traps but you
increase the amount of enemies spawn
points and the risk of getting separated
from your team there's a positive sense
of trial and error when figuring out
what Park expansion progression works
for you and your friends
keep pushing
by venturing beyond earth hollow duty
found a canvas to produce its best store
in years it reinforces the notion that
the game's narrative is only as good as
the character you play and their
surrounding caste given the campaign's
accomplishments in space combat it's
puzzling that no effort was made to
replicate its zero-g sensations in
infinite Warfare's multiplayer
consequently the well crafted zombies
mode is a more attractive time-consuming
proposition for those looking to play
with friends while no entry has matched
a comprehensive excellence of call of
duty 4 modern warfare the exploits of
Ray's and Ethan are at least as
memorable and moving as any deeds from
soap MacTavish and John price from the
series's heyday